there's always been something a little
off about Thanos and his quest for
galactic domination and there's nothing
to do with how much he likes sitting
down it's all about the Infinity
Gauntlet the artifact that Thanos will
apparently wield in Avengers infinity
war and the strange fact that there
seems to be more than one in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe I only ask that you
take this matter seriously we first got
a glimpse of the Infinity Gauntlet which
is specifically constructed to hold the
powerful Infinity stones in the
background of Odin's trophy room in 2011
s Thor in that scene the gauntlet held
the Infinity stones and was made for a
right hand which is a subtly significant
detail the next time we saw the gauntlet
was during a mid-credits scene after
2015's Avengers age of Ultron vanos
reached into a vault put on a glove with
no stones on it and held it up it looked
to be on the left hand this time but
questions still lingered about his
possession of the artifact like how
could Fanus get the gauntlet when it's
supposed to be safely stowed away in
Asgard and aren't the Infinity stones
supposed to be scattered around the
universe anyway two years ago
Marvel's Kevin Feige told cinema blend
there's a simple explanation saying
there are two different gloves that was
not Odin's fault that you see at the end
of age of Ultron all right that sounds
simple enough but not everyone read that
interview
and besides Marvel's not always known
for being so forthright
however thor ragnarok has now proven
that indeed
Feige was telling the truth in the film
we see hell a storm Odin's castle and
walk around his trophy room to reveal
that lots of the trophies are actually
fake including the first seen Infinity
Gauntlet which she unceremoniously
knocks over so that solves that now the
stage is set for infinity war and fog
ease back story checks out there are two
gloves Thanos has one of them and he
might just make good on that promise
after all
storm whiz in your blood now we just
have to wait to find out if Thanos has
got the real deal and whether and how
he'll put his Infinity Gauntlet to use
when the Avengers infinity war hits
theaters on April 25th 2018 I'm gonna
miss these little talks of Oz thanks for
watching click the looper I comment
subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all the school stuff we know
you'll love to
[Music]